the gyro can experience that's one of
the more important parts of being a
person right is to really your diet of
what you take in in terms of what
whatever whether it's your art or
whether it's your education try to take
in the the best and most inspirational
and the most spectacular versions of
human human endeavors absolutely see
that's one of reasons why Sports is an
American religion
sure because in sports or whatever for I
know that you got Taekwondo and thing
yeah yeah I mean and you understand the
role of excellence with the grid Scott
are tazed at that place but to be able
just to turn on our television and see
brother LeBron James Dean thing that's
another context that cuts across race
class gender and so forth
LeBron how you do it did memories of
Mike Jordan it was so important I when
he sat out those three years in the late
1960s because he wouldn't go to Vietnam
courage man Muhammad Ali along with
Richard Pryor to Richard it was a freest
black black man the 20th century but see
that the boxing is so crucial as well as
the other the the other sports because
for black people every other sphere in
the society is unfair and unfree but
when you get in that ring and the
referee is fair hmm you finally get fair
competition yeah
that's why Jack Johnson was such a
threat remember Johnson walking white
brothers out there would be racial riots
against black folk killing black folk
all across the country don't you get the
idea and just because he beat the white
man in the context of fairness yeah that
you can beat anybody right and that goes
all the way to Muhammad Ali
it's very stirring you know the time I
spent with another genius named Prince
because we missed so so so very much
this nobody liked it but he like Miles
Davis view Jack Johnson that's his
favorite black me mm-hmm in that
interesting well he was a pioneer
because there was none before him Jack
Johnson was Jack generally the first
by him by himself in many way there was
one I think but not as famous not a
saint but in terms of the spotlight yeah
there was other great boxers this time
but he but he just took it I didn't
leave the country and so forth yeah see
and what Muhammad Ali you know you got
someone who was just himself in the
context of a social movement that was
taking place at the same time so he
would associate himself with the black
freedom movement called a civil rights
movement he joined the Nation of Islam
under honorable eyes of Mohammed vain
became then we came very close to
Malcolm X and had to deal with the split
in its own way and ultimately becomes
you know AM Orthodox Muslim but at the
same time recognizes his political
consciousness was tied to the Nation of
Islam and so forth and for him to do
that I mean to be associated with the
art of Elijah Muhammad the Nation of
Islam probably had about 0.1% approval
in the country and probably about four
or five percent in the black community
because at that time black folk and
black Christians were just afraid you
know the black Muslims but it was
Malcolm X who in it all of his genius
made it so broadly conceived that even
Christians like myself I'm a Jesus
loving free black man but I can't live
my life without Malcolm mmm you see and
he's Muslim to the core right he's
praying five times a day you know what I
mean that's just the beginning of he's
also very complicated too because his
grandfather was white well he was white
his father was a Garvey I his mother was
tied to the iteration but fathers Garvey
idea was killed his mother of course
puttin us in a sane asylum he's a foster
child the great stories he tells in the
autobiography of malcolm x one of the
great classics really memoirs in history
of american civilization was very
misunderstood in terms of what the
cultural narrative of who he was
absolutely no it's true he used to say
sincerity is my only credential in the
powerful
sincerity so when he said white men and
women are Devils and he believed he's
wrong white brothers sisters not Devils
then he says I changed my mind
they're not Devils they too many got
devilish behavior he's right because
that's due up too many of all of us out
Devils baby see but when he said the
first thing he said what he meant he
meant what he said when he said the
second thing he said what he meant he
meant what you said you know how many
folk do we have like that right a day
that aren't scared to change their mind
and and speak what's des Oh
[Applause]